hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from yesterday's speed
chess championship match between jeffrey
xiong and wesley so now it's a game you
don't see very often especially between
uh
such strong players and uh you know i've
received a lot of messages to show this
game and usually when i get the oh this
is a brilliant game and then i check it
out it's usually a so-so game so often
people like to exaggerate in their
suggestions but this uh this is not one
such example this game truly is
magnificent it's very very short only a
handful of moves um well less than 30
that's what we consider a miniature
today uh and you guys will enjoy it so
without further ado let's check it out
xiong with the white pieces opens with
knight to f3 he goes for the red opening
uh we have d5 by wesley c4 and now uh d
for advancing the pawn so this is uh
declining the red gambit and now now
white usually goes g3 here i think it
was the light square bishop and you know
just continues nicely developing but
also incredibly popular is just pawn to
b4
uh as it is in many other openings and
you know uh keep an eye on this b4 pawn
for for the rest of the game yeah it uh
you know will have a very important role
to play uh we have f6 by wesley
preparing to advance the pawn to e5 to
create a very solid center here we have
e3 challenging the center and now uh e5
nicely defending the center and now uh
this opened up the bishop's attack
towards the b4 pawn so we have to play
c5 to defend it and now wesley attacks
the b for pawn with a5
and as you can see both players are kind
of ignoring their development at least
the development of pieces you can see
wesley's pieces he still hasn't
developed a single piece only pushing
pawns whereas uh
xing only has a knight to develop so
here we have queen to a for check and
now c6 and this is uh where things start
to get really interesting this is a
known position and best moves for black
are queen d7 and bishop to d7 just
blocking but the move wesley place
allows whites to go for some
at least a little bit advantage so here
we have bishop to c4
and now uh known moves here on knight to
a6 and knight to h6 but wesley plays
knight to e7 uh and it is now uh only as
of move seven that we have a completely
new game so let's see how white
continues white simply castles the
safety and now knights the a6 you can
never capture on b4 because the rook
here is hanging so we first have to
develop some pieces we have knight to
the e6 uh and then now comes a3 adding
more defense to that b for pawn uh very
interestingly uh e captures on d4 is uh
is a great move but this is a blitz game
it's a five plus one i don't know if
i've mentioned this so players don't
really have all that much time to
calculate the point is uh you can't
really capture back if you capture back
then we play bishop b2 and this pawn
will still fall if you advance it to d3
we can simply play queen b3 now bishop
to f7 is a
terrible thread rook is coming to e1
knight c3 i mean it's just um
everything is working for white here but
okay it's a blitz game we have a3 and
now a captures on b for a captures on b4
and now knights to c7 so now the knight
defends the rook uh and uh the queen is
attacked so obviously the queen can't
move and defend the rook on a1 so uh
xiong's idea here was to simply give up
the queen so queen captures an a8 knight
captures an a8 and rook captures an a8
and okay it's a queen sacrifice for a
rook and a minor piece uh plus the
attack you know some bishop to e6 action
could be very unpleasant but black has
all the compensation in the world and he
starts with the g5 he wants to dislodge
the knight with the g4 uh so e captures
on d4 and now
what do you play here well uh you should
just continue with the g4 but wesley
played e4
and that this allows white to throw in
this very unpleasant move rook to e1 and
now not only does he give up the queen
he now gives up the knight on f3 so
wesley captures this we have e captures
on f3 and now bishop to e6 now putting
pressure on this bishop here and
basically xiang is saying do you want to
give back the queen because black if
black wants to he can play bishop
captures and e6 we're going to pick up
the queen and then pick up the bishop
here and it's a pretty equal in the game
white is up upon for the moment but uh
you know you you have to kind of react
to this so it doesn't really matter so
this is one possibility but wesley
doesn't want the equality he wants to
play for the win and he plays queen
captures on d4 and now it's a it's a
very dangerous position uh we have
bishop captures on c8 you can't go for
rook captures on c8 if rook captures
knight captures you don't have any good
discoveries here uh with the bishop um
you know the queen the bishop the rooker
and dark squares and if you just capture
this with a discovery king v8
there's really nothing for for white
here so instead after queen captures on
d4 we have bishop captures now again
threatening some nasty discoveries and
wesley hides the king with king to f7
and now black is uh
all of a sudden black is fine we have
bishop back the e6 check king to g6 and
now knight to c3
and here like we mentioned uh black is
doing incredibly well you have to you
know develop some pieces for example
bishop the g7 offers a trade of rooks
this is fine uh f5 also blocking the
bishop's um uh protection of the g4
square preparing queen to g4 this is
excellent for black but wesley plays
queen captures on b4 i hope you were
watching that uh b4 pawn
and well as in many cases this again
will decide the game uh so here we have
knight to e4 uh interestingly rook to e4
is also very impressive for example if
queen captures on c5 bishop a3 uh and
that's just it uh white will have um you
know all the advantage that he needs
after captures if bishop captures you're
going to lose the rook as well but i
have to remember or rather remind you
guys this is a blitz game so knight the
e4 and now uh bishop to g7 finally
offering that trade of rooks but now
comes rook to a3 white of course
declines this and he wants to bring the
rook to f3 so here we have knight to d5
uh and now comes knight to d6 so here
white is threatening some very nasty
stuff and you have to be very very
careful about how you play this uh
bishop to f8 is what you should play but
in the game wesley played knight to f4
and now yes you have a lot of pressure
you're putting a lot of pressure on g2
on on e2
but this also means that you are getting
checkmated in two moves uh this is what
wesley missed and unfortunately for him
uh xiung immediately played it so here
white played bishop to f7 check and he
was in this position on move 22 that
wesley so resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here only move
for the black king is king to h6 and
then knight to f5 will deliver checkmate
uh and that's it uh so uh xiong wins a
brilliant brilliant game here it's uh
been a while uh you know since i've seen
someone uh crush a super grandmaster
like this you know sacrificing the queen
then sacrificing the knight on f3 and
then just you know checkmating the the
the blocking with the minor pieces it's
just a a a beauty to
you know experience such a thing no not
being on the receiving end but as a
spectator it's it's really really
incredible so hope you guys enjoyed this
um if you guys haven't seen it wesley in
the end won the match i think the result
end result was something like 14 to 12
or maybe even 16 to 12. i'm not sure but
wesley was the victory in the end but
xiung got this brilliancy as a
consolation prize you know for everyone
to enjoy
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it another example of why
it's important to use hashtag suggestion
a lot of you have requested this game so
in the end i i did see it and i was able
to you know show it to even more people
uh so thank you for that so yeah once
again hope you enjoyed it i would like
to thank dave neve uh darwin's twitter
benjamin echenlor uh branislav
and frank louis for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
uh of the team event that we were
covering uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day